here we have horchata boba yes sometime
love is found in very weird places and
today it was found in Asia and Mexico a
selfie
I guess I'm but go eat with the business
dumbass right here it took about 2 hours
do that face ok took 5 minutes he
drugged me and nothing happened
another thing that you don't know about
Nina when she sleeps she sleeps with the
most angry [ __ ] face on earth
my father resting [ __ ] there's a
resting [ __ ]
and then there's your face you look like
you wanted to murder somebody when I
woke up I thought you were angry at me I
probably wasn't writer you [ __ ] this
right here is their simon de luxe if you
guys don't know what simon is Simon Says
no that's not it at all
this right here is Filipino food so you
have pork adobo and then a gwaan now
dinner Guan is an interesting dish they
call it like chocolate meat but here
yeah I'd like to do a chocolate it's
just a blood his blood gets it's blood
your grow you will eat anything but you
eat pig but your vampire no no no tell
them what if stuff that you like
anything else dude we are here in Maui
at a lava rock location I don't know
Joseph is here but area water comes up
we need get to go out earlier because I
uh I actually told you guys about that
heat rash I had but come out here
anyways spray myself with baby powder
she could see butts I've been known like
I've been doing coke all day huh Yee
baby kind of cool isn't it look at it
yeah am i ruining the scenery am I not
good enough for you we are out here in
the scenic ass Valley it's a little bit
different from what we're used to um
usually we're at a beach but now we're
at a mountainside with a lot of
[ __ ] trees gangsta style Rambo
style this reminds me of a what's that
movie predator yawn room in that movie
with that big arrest tall dude you got
dreadlocks in the back and condos like
t-pain I guess down towards the beach is
a lot harder but hotter harder I should
harder for Dean flip I want to see a
[ __ ] monkey look at that
village ass [ __ ] right there man that
shit's villages [ __ ] look like
Aborigines and [ __ ] living there I lost
to go down oh my god that's a bug on me
trying to bite me buying into that oh
this tree just poked me my arm I'm gonna
tell you something now so we all know
the jungle cats like fat people I'm fat
as [ __ ]
it's you can feel the fire girl is
blazing lately I'm feeling kind of crazy
I look at this Creek
that's where [ __ ] take baths
and [ __ ] [ __ ] wash their drawers
and [ __ ] Hawaiian style guess what we're
doing we chilling next to a goddamn
River my friends that's right
you know why they have a saying that the
rivers of Maui are our God's tears of
Kamehameha here we have a Mexican
Thundercat chillin by herself as you can
see she was doing her mating call but
it's not working on anybody but Bart
because that [ __ ] is disgusting she
struts again there you go she looked
darkest [ __ ] now oh that's the happy
face I feel oh [ __ ] Joe the fitnah knees
Rambo that jungle refugee first he looks
around to see where can he jump maybe
this one maybe that one I don't know
yeah at the contemplate life I wonder
what's my next move Rock number one
dance cross number two curtain go Rock
number
three this one's a difficult one that's
because there's water [ __ ] here we go
hey don't be a [ __ ] so how do you feel
baby wake up honest man make a girl it's
us against the world shouted [ __ ] them
haters you're so major look what you
done to me baby got me so crazy but I
can't do it for you